Well, we're now using the sync adapter, and things are
working pretty much as before. We want the app to do
this synchronization cleverly, and we'd like to get rid of
that old Refresh menu item. Let's start by cleaning up all
the other routines we have to sync. So we certainly
don't need any of this other stuff like FetchWeatherTask, or all
this stuff we did in Sunshine service, and we'll want to clean
up the manifest accordingly. We certainly don't need either one of
these anymore. And in Preferences, we can just change
that to sync immediately. So now we're really using this
sync adapter everywhere. We have a problem though. We're not
being very smart. The user still has all sorts of
places where they see an empty list. We want to
sync more intelligently. In Android 2.2 Froyo, Android added the
ability to have sync adapter's sync periodically. We can add
a helper method to do this in our sync adapter.
The problem is, this method isn't as smart as
we'd like it to be, it still won't do all
that cool batching with exact repeating alarms that we'd
like it to. Fortunately, we've added something that does just
that, but it's not available until API level 19.
Taking advantage of flexible time to do inexact repeating arms,
let's set some nice defaults for our Sunshine sync adapter.
First we'll add these constants. To make things a little
clearer in our code let's add another function
that we'll call when a new account is created,
and here we'll set some important flags. Such as
configurePeriodicSync, the one we
just created. SetSyncAutomatically, without which
our periodic sync will not be enabled. Since we're
just starting off let's do an immediate sync, then
we can call it from a strategic place and
get sync account. Finally, we can make the interface
to the world a little bit cleaner by
adding an initializeSyncAdapter function. That's simply makes sure
that an account has been created. And now
inside of the main activity in the onCreate, we
can just make a call to that new
function. And it'll make sure that the parameters for
our sync adapter are set up correctly. let's
see if this has any impact on our emulator.
The new version of Sunshine right from the start shows all of current
weather. For a sync with a sync
adapter to happen successfully at periodic intervals
in the background you must: have a
ContentProvider marked as syncable, enable automatic sync
for the SyncAdapter, do an initial immediate
sync, or set an interval in milliseconds.